(crowd cheers enthusiastically)
- All right, it's almost time to go
but I want to leave
you with one last story
to lift your spirits!
This is what I'm liking:
(jovial jingle)
Let me introduce you to Braxton.
At 20 years old, he just
became our country's
youngest lawyer.
He's already lived an extraordinary life.
At 10, he was taking college courses.
Through middle and high school,
he was also working toward his Bachelor's
at Harvard, so we were on a similar track.
(audience laughs)
In fact, he's the only student
in the university's history
to graduate high school
and Harvard simultaneously.
(audience applauds and cheers)
What??
He went on to graduate law school
two years later, and earlier this year
he passed the Bar, no big deal,
we have Braxton on the line right now
watching from KSNW Wichita.
What's up Braxton?
- Hi, how are you?
- I'm not as awesome as you, but like
you're- congratulations!
You're just extraordinary!
So where were you when you found out
that you passed the Bar?
- So, we'd actually just
entered a movie theater.
Scrolling through social media,
saw one of my friends got their scores,
figured my score's probably in as well,
started to panic,
found out I passed, my
parents were ecstatic,
and we saw the movie.
- And we saw-
and we watched the movie!
(laughs incredulously)
I love it!
I love-
you're casual-
(stutters)
you moved your cat like, so effortlessly,
that was nice work.
So are you working yet?
- I haven't decided on a law firm
or anything yet.
I had an externship with the local
county/city attorney.
You have to kind of be more than one thing
out here 'cause it's so desolate.
You know, tried a few people
for traffic infractions,
I got 'em.
I mean, they were on camera,
but that's beside the
point, I still got 'em.
(Kelly and audience chuckle)
And I'm keepin' our city safer.
(Kelly laughs)
That's my interest; trials, litigation,
that sort of thing.
- Oh my God.
You are, you're such an amazing young man.
Thank you so much Braxton
and congratulations again.
(audience cheers enthusiastically)
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell dings)
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G-2, the go to pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor ultimate overachievers
just like you sir, so they're-
I don't know if anyone
is like you, but sure.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000 , how's that sound?
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Kelly giggles)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, good luck in life!
You are super blessed, man!
Hard worker!